ساعدتنا [موسيقى]
العودة إلى المستقبل على تخيل
كيف كنا سنتحرك
يومًا ما كنا نحلم بهذا
المستقبل لقرون على
ما يبدو أننا نحلم حقًا في بعض الأحيان ،
أعني أن هذه الأجنحة التنين على أي حال 2015.
الجدول الزمني للدكتور براون لم ينجح تمامًا
لكن النماذج الأولية للنقل اليوم
تعيد تشكيل عالم الغد ،
دعني فقط أكتشف كيفية تبديلها ،
لذا فأنت تشغل معظم
شاشتي
هناك ، ننتقل الآن إلى وسائل النقل التي تمر الآن
بتحول جوهري
مشابه تمامًا لما
رأيناه مع  القاطرة في القرن التاسع
عشر
ثم اختراع السيارة في
القرن العشرين ، كل شيء يتغير الآن
يمكننا أن نتخيله حول الحزم النفاثة
hyperloops والسفر في الفضاء شبه المداري ،
كل هذه الأفكار قيد التطوير ولكن
المركبات المستقلة قد يكون لها تأثير أكبر
بحلول عام 2040  يمكن أن تمثل ما يصل
إلى ثلثي المسافة المقطوعة
في
السيارات الصينية فقط لتصبح
منصات حوسبة متنقلة وأشخاص  يجب أن نكون متحمسين
لأن ما ننتهي إليه
هو عالم أفضل شيء أكثر أمانًا
وأكثر ملاءمة ،
ما زلنا على بعد عقود قليلة من هذا
العالم ولكن لدينا الأدوات التي تمكننا من الوصول إلى
هناك
كل ذلك بفضل ارسالا ساحقا
ما الآن ارسالا ساحقا  يشير إلى الاتجاهات الأربعة الكبرى
التي تعمل على تحويل
المركبات الكهربائية والمشتركة المتصلة بالنقل المستقل
أولاً إلى الاستقلالية google tesla
uber ، لقد حصلوا جميعًا على سيارات بدون سائق
يتفق معظم الخبراء على ستة مستويات من
الأتمتة بشكل
مربك مع كون خمسة هي الأعلى
لأن المقياس يبدأ من الصفر
حيث  هل ترغب في الذهاب إلى العديد من
المركبات ذاتية القيادة اليوم إلى المستوى
الثاني أو
الثالث لتتولى المهام الأساسية مثل وقوف السيارات
وتبديل الممرات ،
لكن هذا يغير سريعًا من الناس يعتقدون أن
هذا شيء بعيد
المنال ، إنه ليس طريقًا مملوكًا لـ
Google
هو مركبة من المستوى الرابع  وضع قيد
الإنتاج ، هذا ليس اختبارًا تجريبيًا ، بل
هو مباشر اليوم
للوصول إلى استقلالية حقيقية ، نحتاج إلى مساعدة من
حرفنا الثاني
لهذه الأطروحات  السيارات الإلكترونية للتنقل بأمان
يحتاجون إلى التواصل ليس فقط مع بعضهم
البعض
ولكن مع كل شيء تقريبًا العديد من
السيارات متصلة بالفعل اليوم
قل أمرًا أو قل ساعدنا
ولكن للمركبات ذاتية القيادة لبدء
التحدث إلى العالم الأوسع
يحتاج الذكاء الاصطناعي للتقدم
و  من المحتمل أن تصبح سياراتنا المتصلة ذاتية القيادة كهربائية لشبكة الجيل الخامس 5g ،
ولكن لا تزال هناك بعض المشكلات حول المدى الذي
يمكن أن تصل إليه السيارات الكهربائية ،
ولكن ستتم معالجة هذه المشكلات مع ظهور
المزيد من محطات الشحن
، ومع اعتياد المزيد من الأشخاص على
التكنولوجيا ، فإن
رسالتنا الأخيرة هي  ربما لا يعني الأمر الأكثر
اعتمادًا على أول ثلاثة
تنقل مشترك فقط أن
خدمات مشاركة الركوب
تشير ناسا أيضًا إلى أشياء مثل الدراجات البخارية
والدراجات الكهربائية ،
وأنماط النقل المختلفة التي
يجدها الناس مريحة ،
لذا فإن الفكرة هنا هي أنه بدلاً من
امتلاك سيارة بنفسك
والاضطرار إلى ذلك  تعامل مع تكلفة تلك
السيارة ، يمكنك مشاركة
تكلفة ذلك ، حيث تحتاج السيارات إلى أن تصبح
أكثر ذكاءً ج  تشغيل أرخص وأكثر كفاءة ،
وهذا هو السبب وراء قيام العديد من
شركات مشاركة الرحلات بالاستثمار في التكنولوجيا بدون سائق
، وهذا صحيح لأن هذه
ليست أربعة اتجاهات مستقلة ، فهذه
كلها مرتبطة ببعضها البعض ، وهذا في
الحقيقة يتعلق بتقديم التنقل كخدمة
[موسيقى]